we ready to chest test our mental
toughness
yes Paul is anything about anyone in the
room worried that he's gonna tell you
something that's gonna maybe should help
you but more like get in your own head
mm-hmm you know where it could be like
oh I didn't know I had that flaw or that
fault I think we're in our own heads
Werder Trevor come on in Trevor
Trevor's written a book look at you all
dressed up got a suit on okay all right
so I gotta get everybody so Todd you
want a handout whatever here with UDP oh
it takes what it takes the mindset
manual and it's got our pictures on the
cover got your pictures yeah why winners
win all right
explain what your job is try Bob pull
that microphone a few guys can help him
one of the camera people make sure okay
yeah perfect
yeah go explain for the layman what you
do well I guess the only real consumer
facing brand that people kind of in
general would know would be sort of Tony
Robbins and and and I would say what I
do is probably a lot different than that
but but my job really starting at IMG
the sports agency IMG Academy and then
ultimately go into the Jacksonville
Jaguars then Alabama then for to state
then a lot of places is to really focus
on how to help our our really good
players get better but but how to help
people get out of their own way
psychologically so I'm not a clinical
psychologist like if you said hey go
down to help Antonio Brown right now I
would say I would be you know have
better luck playing in traffic than
helping him who was the one what was the
the biggest challenge you had with an
athlete or coach well I probably say the
the early challenge I had was the
running back Fred Taylor Fred oh yeah
when Coach Coughlin originally hired me
he wanted to play all 16 games and you
know he really didn't know how to unpack
that and and I think what you figure out
and I think the book talks about the
stand is is how do you learn to do
simple better you know Joe Madden talked
about it all the time how do you do the
basic things
Fred wanted to play 16 games we found
out two days into it that there were 17
guys on the jaguars that that had played
two contracts or were going into three
contracts is back when they had Keaney
Makar Del Mark Brunell all those guys
and all Fred want to do is play 16 games
if you remember his nickname back then
it was fragile Fred and that's not a
good nickname for a running back and so
we found out that of the 17 guys that
had played two contracts there were two
common denominators that all of them had
they all showed up at either 6:30 in the
morning or earlier and they all took ice
baths at the end of the day and so we
sat down Fred we said all right if you
commit to doing this for the rest of the
year we think this is gonna give you
your best chance to play all 16 games
he's like what am I gonna do is 6:30 in
the morning I have no idea there must be
something these guys do and I don't like
ice bass will create aqua socks for you
and ultimately it's amazing but
something simple like that Fred played
46 games in a row ultimately retired
with you know 11,500 yards I'm just
short of Jim Brown and and it's the
basic things I think how do you unravel
little things like that but you had
Russell Wilson who's a client of course
friend of the show he throws the
interception in the super yes they're
gonna win their second yep and then he
throws the interception yep how do you
unpack that and build back maybe you
don't need to but you know you you you
you need to I think what people don't
know is the the most televised event in
the history of the United States was
mashed you know the mash finale yeah
when in the final two minutes of that
game and Andy staples who was a friend
of the show I know who you know who
wrote this who wrote the book with me
I'm a hundred and twenty four million
people were watching the final two
minutes of the the New England Seattle
game the most televised moment in the
history of the United States
when Russell throws that interception so
it's a big moment and what he did was he
went back and he watched film and he
evaluated it and did what he normally
did but the only thing we controlled Dan
was the offseason so we said we got to
get out of Seattle because Seattle is
having a really difficult time
controlling this thing and we got to go
down to San Diego and the only thing
that we control is having the best
offseason of your career now what I did
was I put together every
fourth-quarter comeback that he had
played been a part of since high school
so I had over 35 fourth-quarter
comebacks and every morning in the
offseason we watched a fourth-quarter
comeback so reminded him of who he was
and what he was all about and then we
hired you know a great strength coach
and one of the top trainers had a great
offseason and ultimately he threw 35
touchdowns seven picks and had the best
season of his career following that year
you've advised Nick Saban yeah yes but
eight seasons at the University of
Alabama and one season with the Miami
Dolphins now do you have to help Saban
with confidence are you helping his
players with confidence well one of the
great things about Coach Saban which I
think was different than Coach Coughlin
was he utilized a lot of different
people so there were six different sort
of mental experts helping the University
of Alabama program six six different
experts and and if you think about right
now the 132 college football programs
nobody has anybody in Alabama had six
and and nobody knows it because it's
kind of a unique value proposition so I
was one of many pieces you know but my
job was kind of like that workbook you
have in the summer we would have when
you lift and do seven on seven every
week twice a week we would do mental
conditioning and we would just teach our
players the fundamentals of thinking we
would study use this visualization well
we don't really teach the power of
positive thinking or meditation okay
what we've learned is that negative
thinking is the killer and if you can
minimize negativity then you don't need
to be more positive can you be
overconfident I think you can be
overconfident I think that would be
called grandiosity
when when when you expect wood maybe
when your expectations are ahead of your
training and delusional you would be I
don't know delusion would be probably
different but but you you expect more
than your body's probably capable of the
output the book is called it takes what
it takes I put that it takes what it
takes well so I was working with the
Memphis Grizzlies and I was having a
conversation with Vince Carter and we
were sort of talking about three players
who had who had been arrested and they
were struggling and he said how
any of those guys that play college
football want to play professional
football and I said you know to be
honest that for two state Alabama
Georgia any of these places probably 7
out of 10 and he said you know isn't it
funny that they think they can do
whatever they want and still be a
professional athlete I said what do you
mean he said well I'm 38 years old and
there's only a limited amount of things
I can do and and play at 38 you know I
can't dunk as much now because when I
land I takes me longer to get back and I
can't eat fast food after different
things and I have to lift the day's the
games and all the different things and I
said well what do you mean he said I
said that there are no choices he said
choice is an illusion it takes what it
takes and so that there's a there's a
finite way to be good to be good at what
you do it takes what it takes you don't
have to do it but to me what I've seen
Dan in 18 years is average people become
average through average aptitude or
through average behavior not an average
aptitude like Russell Russell has a
really good aptitude but his behavior
what he does when I first met Russ he
comes out to IMG Academy I meet him with
Chris Weinke remember Chris will give
the quarterback yeah we go up we meet
him and I might get first 10 minutes and
you had to be this way I'm like is this
dude for real I still say it right I'm
like I mean he's he's so polished he's
so buttoned up and he told he knew
everything about me he said I know you
worked with Drew Brees 11 years earlier
I want to study everything that drew did
I want to know you know all the
different mental things I want to know
how he answered every question being
under six feet and and then he met with
me three times a week in addition to to
doing all the things normal combine guys
though it was it was incredible it's the
book is called it takes what it takes
Trevor Matt is joining us here you know
he's a renowned mental conditioning
expert in strategic advisor I if you
were going to do a test on it is test
the right word yeah well so there's that
will be an exercise with there's
probably two things we'll do one but
probably the biggest stress skills we're
seeing right now Dan is and my goal of
Russ said my goal is I've got it I've
got to do a good enough job to be the
official mental conditioning consultant
for the damn Pat oh oh okay so I I've
obviously got to earn this thing so this
is this is again now but our our
premises you don't need to be sick to
get better so you guys are already
really good so our job is to help you
get better I mean I think everybody here
is pretty
so so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do
one of the things that you would do with
the NFL Combine day three if you were
getting ready for the draft if you were
one of the 300 people invited okay so
does everybody got their book I got my
book here okay so now so we're gonna
have to ultimately eventually get into
where we're gonna partner but I want you
to turn to page 14 age 14 page 14 now
you're gonna have I'm already nervous
you're gonna have this thing called test
one everybody see test one it has all
the numbers between 1 and 99
concentration test one concentration
test 1 now what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna give you 30 seconds when I say go
I'm gonna give you a starting number now
I know how some of you got through
college so keep your eyes on your own
paper but I'm gonna give you does
everybody got it right now hold your
book up so I can see y'all okay so you
have to have a pen in your hand okay
when I say go I'm gonna give you a
starting number that number might be 77
you got to find 77 you got to put an X
through 77 and you got to find as many
numbers in consecutive descending order
okay you're gonna have theevening
descending order so anybody go to 4 to
state okay I want to challenge you if I
say descending I know you might get a
little bit nervous about any 4 state
seminoles here but 77 the next number in
consecutive order would be what 76 76
okay so I'm gonna move out of my desk
and engage a little bit I'm gonna watch
you guys oh but but but you know what
let me take a break here take a break
yeah let's take a break we'll get ready
we'll get everybody really ready yeah
piano break it's gonna take us at least
how long ago to check it's gonna take to
do all three it's gonna take us probably
about two and a half minutes two and a
half minutes let's go let's do it no
good yeah all right so when I say go I'm
gonna give you a starting number and you
got to find as many numbers in
consecutive descending order okay yeah
so test one we're starting right now
we're gonna start with the number 99 and
go it's not live mic work oh yeah it is
okay so I'm gonna tell you 30 seconds
twenty seconds ten seconds so 25 seconds
remaining
there is a 97 dan yeah I know I'm trying
to find the damn thing mm 15 seconds
remaining I'm gonna need you are you
sure there's a 97 on here yes
5 seconds remaining can stop okay you
come up here I need 90 right now I need
everybody get a partner turn to test to
get a part of turn to test you coming up
here coming up here brother you're gonna
partner with Dan all right so I want to
win two front row and back you're good
yep so just just slide over right next
to him you're gonna go over here a
partner with Dan all right okay you're
gonna look at Dan so when I say go this
time all you're gonna do is lean over
your partner's shoulder one of you is
gonna watch him on test - so you're
gonna watch them and then you're gonna
switch and then you're gonna count for
the other guys so put your hands we're
gonna watch your partner first
okay this is the exact thing you would
do at the NFL Combine day three okay so
when I say go I'm gonna give you a new
starting number you know you're gonna
lean over you're gonna watch your
partner and then we're gonna switch okay
so next next thing we're gonna start
with the number 68 and go we're going
descending consecutive descending order
[Music]
is she supposed to be helping me out
nope you're just watching him okay 20
seconds remaining
10 seconds very good and stop switch
partners
okay there you go brother you're gonna
watch DP right here you got mine
terrible he's gonna watch you okay next
partner up I'm exact same exercise we
start with the number 51 and go just one
let's roll 51 just test 3 test tube 2
you not to test 3 yet we're almost the
test 351 lean over solder and count form
51 51 15 seconds remaining there's got
to be a reason why this is confusing
consecutive descending order there is a
48 5 seconds
very good and style now this time we're
gonna do something we call trash-talking
your job is to do everything you can to
distract your partner from finding the
number you cannot physically touch them
we're in the hashtag the hashtag world
but my job is to do everything I can we
get to test three to distract you so I
can yell I can make as much noise as I
want first of all make sure you write
your score down on each of the top two
so how many you crossed out on the top
two so write down your score so Dan
write down your score yeah so now your
partner what's your partner's name
Grayson Grayson so you're gonna do
everything you can I'm gonna help you to
distract Dan from finding the number
okay so that means you can you can yell
you can get into space you can do
whatever you can oh and we're good this
is all connected to the power of
concentration which is the most stressed
skill in 2020 so put your hand up if
you're gonna talk the trash first great
you guys okay okay this time test three
starting with the number 41 and yeah
where you at deeper 41 41 number 41 is
the number down four three two oh my god
stop tell your partner how many he got I
was horrible four
okay next partner up all right Grayson
you got to go this time you got to go
this time partner up last time this time
we're starting with the number 31 and
yeah who calls her kin gracious
why don't you go get me breakfast right
now you got four you did the same as me
way to go great now get out of here
Trevor let's take a break here yeah we
gotta regroup here y'all survive god
this just brought back bad memories of
high school in college all right we'll
take a break we'll come back and see how
we did right up to this just it wasn't a
test it was how would you describe what
we just did Trevor oh it was it was sort
of an experience of of kind of like a
game kind of a series of moments
basically you had the exact same
assessment that you took and you took it
three times and what was you had to find
numbers in consecutive descending order
how many of you found that that your
results were a little bit different or
it felt a little bit different each time
you took it anybody in that situation I
was far better with the last one you're
far better they I was more comfortable
with somebody yelling at me okay now
there's just a couple basic truths and
this is what we were always focusing on
at Alabama for two state Georgia
US Army Special Operations Command the
fundamentals of thinking like what are
the basic truths the simple fact of the
matter is you can only think about one
thing at a time so as Russell's going
through that final drive Russell focuses
on three things Russell Wilson Russell
Wilson great balance great fundamentals
being engaged okay so you can only think
about one thing at a time so when your
mind is focused on the next number we
got about 45 seconds yeah when your
minds focus on the next number you're
most effective when it's focused on the
person yelling at you
you can't because you can only think
about one thing at a time so in this
exercise the only thing that changed was
the environment so if you think about
sports what's constantly changing you're
playing in front of coaches you're not
the combine is the ultimate thing you're
playing there's no there's no crowd just
stop watches so you can only think about
one thing at a time so the environment
changed what's a good number on these
guys I think if you can get six seven or
eight we only did 30 seconds normally we
do 90 seconds but but the goal was if
your focus so the last time when you
went all are focused on the next number
yeah so if you can keep it on the next
number not the other thing trevor Malad
the book is it takes what it takes how
to think neutrally and gain control of
your life available online wherever
books are sold the mental conditioning
expert strategic advisor and Russell
Wilson's mental coach Trevor thanks for
coming in this was a blast
fascinating thank you guys for you fixed
us now look at us yelling at me the
number was 31 seems 113 at 13 and once I
got the 31 then I started on boom boom
boom boom boom
and then I was like relax calm down he
has nothing to do with what I'm doing
correct but as soon as you engage yes 13
yeah then you can't think of 30 why
didn't hear a word he said after I got
but but this is what the sign says your
influence over yourself is 10 times more
powerful than his yeah well it's over
you so it like look I can say to I'll be
patties special sauce those
cheeseburgers I'm gonna sesame-seed bun'
like McDonald's advertised great
commercials to me and I want to have a
Big Mac but outside advertising versus
inside advertising like Russell's ad
campaign the guy he's convinced himself
he's a machine right so as soon as
you're controlling the narrative 31 32
33 34 yeah also looking to see if
there's a pattern yes right a little bit
left I was looking for the pattern
before the whole thing started like
right there any type of that site but
but you asked how Dan does it or in a
Super Bowl or in a big moment when he's
brought it or Maria Menounos and you
know at whatever the situation is
you can only sustain one thought at a
time a great athlete is thinking about
those sub components so Russ when he
walked out in that final thing was all
right I got to get the call from Darrell
Bevell then once I get the call I got
engaged Jermaine Kearse I got engaged
now if soon as his mind goes to the
scoreboard and thinking about that
moment he's dead and that's the
difference I think between the Garoppolo
and a rustle you could see late in the
game the moment gets really big and
Gruffalo starts engaging all these other
things in my opinion whereas Russ is
always focusing on the one thing that is
the right thing I would see all of the
numbers except for the number that I
needed to see except for the last time
the last time I was better it felt in
because well because yeah because the
fact that he was yelling it just felt
like I was more zeroed in where it was
like I have to be more but I float you
know I don't like my attention span is
really limited so when he started
yelling at me I'm like and I'm hearing a
word you're saying dude well they keep
yelling right but that's where if you
start saying basically 45 40 like if
you're telling your form or Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel to 39
on Direct TV stream for free on BR live
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]